-All right, the game is simple.
One at a time, while maintaining
the utmost composure,
we will very slowly
turn our heads,
look into camera, and do
the tiniest head nod possible.
Whoever does
the tinier nod wins.
And you're not allowed to laugh.
Justin, since you're my guest,
you'll be turning first.
Are you ready?
Okay, he's ready.
That way, yeah.
Yeah, that one.
Here he goes.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughs ] Oh, man.
[ Laughter ]
Not bad.
♪♪♪♪
That's pretty good.
Using the head nod.
All right. It's my turn.
Let me have a --
That was perfect.
Let me have a moment here,
and here we go.
I look into this guy?
-[ Laughs ]
-Don't make me laugh.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
It's so stupid. I know. Stop.
All right, all right.
[ Laughter ]
All right. Whew.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dude, this is
sweeping the nation.
Every kid is going to be
playing this game.
All right. It's not easy.
Let's raise the stakes
a little bit.
I'm gonna make you really work
for this one, all right?
You must do the
following things, okay?
First, turn your head
even more slowly.
Look into the camera.
All right. Wait.
Maybe just do it -- I'll say
what to do as you're doing it.
Okay. Cool.
Whew.
♪♪♪♪
[ Whispering ]
Turn your head even more slowly.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
Even more...slow...
Eventually,
look into the camera.
♪♪♪♪
Act like you swallowed a bee.
Give a creepy wink.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] What?!
That was -- [ Laughs ]
What?! You get -- Oh, my gosh!
[ Laughter ]
Look like you're constipated.
♪♪♪♪
Do -- Do that snake neck dance.
[ Laughter ]
And finally give a tiny nod
as though you are saying,
"'Sup."
[ Laughter ]
That is the champ right there.
Justin Timberlake is the winner.